Hey youtubers, what's up?
So this is going to be my Flash episode 10 video.
There were a whole bunch of new characters so I'll try and explain who all of them are from the comics
in addition to my top 5 moments and easter eggs.
So, here we go.
I'll start with a spoiler warning right now because I'm going to explain who all of the comic book characters
are that we saw for the first time.
So, first up, obviously, is Mick Roary, a.k.a. Heatwave, played by Dominic Purcell.
Prison Break reunion all the way, so much fun.
I'll talk about him in top 5 moments, there's a whole bunch I could say about him.
Then we also got the Rathaways. The Rathaways are the really wealthy parents of Pied Piper,
one of the rouges that we're going to see next week in next week's episode.
We met Jason Rush, who's part of the FIRESTORM mythos in the comics. The Show is going to do
something a little bit different with him, but I'll explain in a sec.
And then finally we met end credits teaser new Rouge, who, you know, if you haven't seen the episode yet,
I'm going to wait until I get to the end of the video before I talk about her.
But, very cool person showing up.
So, here we go, getting into top 5 moments, number 5: Flash training montage.
Very strong way to come into the back half of the season.
Like, come in running. Literally. Barry has totally drank Harisson Wells' cool aid in his training so
he could beat the reverse flash eventually.
Funny, because Harisson said that they're partners now.
"I hope that you don't think of me as an enemy."
Probably one of the best lines in the episode. Tom Cavina actually said recently in a bunch of interviews
that every time he has a line, he tries to build in double meanings, in the way that he says things.
So if you feel like something he said sounds ominous, it's on purpose. Like, he's doing that as an actor on purpose.
As cool as Barry turning around and throwing the missile was, really it was Harrison, putting his foot on the ground.
For just, like, for just a brief second they were teasing that he, you know, he might super speed run
and save Barry so that he wouldn't die.
All this Harrison wells partnership reverse flash training is to make Barry better.
We still don't know what Harrison Wells wants to use him for. Presumably it's a causality loop.
That somehow helps Harrison's reverse flash, whatever version of the reverse flash he is.
I still feel like he's the Eobard Thawne version, just beacause he's a little bit smarter.
A lot of people have pointed to the fact that Eddie Thawne could also become really super smart because
if he gets flash powers his brain will work just as fast as Grant Gustin's does.
But when you think about it, Grant Gustin reading those 800 pages, so he had training as a scientist.
Gaining super speed doesn't give you super comprehension. So if Eddie Thawne were to read those 800 pages at superspeed
he'd read the words, but that doesn't necessarily mean that he understands what it means.
That's why I think that Harrison Wells reverse flash is going to be the smarter of the reverse flashes.
Even though during episode 9 I think that's the same reverse flash.
I think it's Harrison Wells from two different times. I know it gets a little complicated, but I think at some point
Eddie Thawne will get reverse flash powers
He'll just be closer to the Hunter Zolomon version. Less scientific, but every bit as dangerous.
Number 4: meet Mick Roary, a.k.a. Heatwave. So I've already done a background video on Heatwave, like an explainer video about him in the comics,
so I'll add a link to that, just in general, let's talk about Dominic Purcell's performance
How much fun was it, seeing him go all creepo on Caitlin. I wonder what the producers told Dominic
whenever they were asking him to take the role, like whenever they were auditioning him.
Mick Roary as a character is a pyromaniac, he is in love with the idea of fire, obsessed with fire.
And I feel like Dominic Purcell did an amazing job at making us feel that.
Clearly he's been touched by flames. Actually in a literal sense.
The really interesting thing about his relationship with Captain Cold is that it kind of mirrors
Barry and Harrison Well's relationship.
They're kind of like frenemies, although Barry doesn't quite know it yet.
One of the characters is just a little more aware of the other. In the case of the rouges, Captain Cold is
tolerating Heatwave.  And in the case of the reverse flash, Harrison Wells is tolerating Barry Allen, because he has to.
One needs the other for a very important plan. In the case of the rogues, they're trying to get that super
valuable painting, in the case of the Flash, that involves time travel.
It doesn't allways happen on every show, but a lot of comic book characters are set up that way,
where they have a diametric opposite, that they have some sort of symbiotic relationship with.
Very awesome to see the official rogues, obviously based on the end of the episode that's only going to continue,
they're only going to grow in ranks. I keep saying it, the back half of the season is going to be very rogue heavy.
The reverse flash is always going to be the biggest villain,
he'll always be the biggest flash villain, but the rogues will fill the void in the man time.
So were going to meet a whole bunch of rogues.
Number 3: Catelin chases down project firestorm and Jason Rush.
This is another really huge comic book moment. Jason Rush is officially on the show now,
apparently not is part of the firestorm
matrix. That's kinda the way they started out in the comics.
Normally Firestorm is made up of two people, Ronny Raymond and Professor Martin Stein,
but at a certain point the comics, Jason Rush became firestorm, Ronny Raymond died, went away, so the show is making a little bit simpler,
they are just going with the original
configuration.
But at some point in the future, Jason
rush could become part of the Firestorm matrix.
But that, I mean, it's a long ways off
they're just getting started with the Firestorm character.
They were at the TCA's. Here's a picture of what the costume is supposed to look like.
Part of the fun of meeting Jason Rush was getting this secondary story line that's gonna run across the back half of this season.
You know what's going on with project
Firestorm, something really shady.
Robbie Amell and Victor Garber - Victor
Garber the actor playing Martin Stein -
they talked about the possibility of a
Firestorm spinoff show.
Right now the only new spin-off that
they're officially working on the CW
is the Atom show for Brandon Routh
character, but it is possible that the next spinoff
may be in like another year or two. If
things go well, there could be a separate
Firestorm show just for Robbie Amell
character,
that is like something floating in the
periphery, so keep that in the back of your mind.
Of all the characters to get a
spinoff he would probably be on the top of the list.
Number 2: Eddie Thawne helps the Flash, and apparently now they're best buds.
Initially, it kind of seemed like Eddie
really hated the Flash based on their
past run in. By the end of the episode,
it seemed like he really respected and loved what the Flash did,
so they might start working together
like you might see a partnership
developed between the Flash,
obviously using his crazy voice, and Eddie Thawne.
Of all the reasons that an Eddie Thawn reverse flash
would hate the crap out of Barry Allen
it could be that he develops a working
relationship with the Flash,
not knowing that he's Barry Allen, then Barry Allen steals his girlfriend in real life,
then he finds out the Flash is Barry Allen and hates his guts.
That's why I think that Iris is going to be much
more important to the back half of the
season.
As a character she's not really central
to the plot right now,
but she's like the wheel around which
Barry in Eddie are turning right now.
I feel like she's gonna become a focal point.
It just feels like a very simple way to
put Eddie Thawne and Barry Allen in opposition.
If you haven't read the comics, Hunter Zolomon was the person that became the
reverse flash, the zoom reverse flash.
He used to be really good friends with Wally West but then
the big tragedy happened: he became the
reverse flash
and then started doing terrible, terrible
things to Wally. It just feels like
they're pushing Eddie Thawne in a Hunter
Zolomon direction.
And my number 1 moment: the
Flash vesus the rogues
and Captain Cold's sister shows up at
the end.
So big action set piece.
Really fun, cross the streams,
Ghostbusters style, I totally love all the shoutouts.
Cisco gets so meta, and I like that
he's kinda got Harrison Wells caught caught up in it, too.
He is the reverse flash but that doesn't
mean that he also doesn't like to have
fun every once in a while
As great is the resolution was it just
it was so much more fun finding out
that it was part of Captain Cold's plan
all along, that they got caught.
Say anything you want about all the
rouges, Captain Cold, though,
is a master planner. He's really good.
Usually when things fall apart,
it's when people like Heatwave go off book.
that's usually the downfall of the rogues, when
they all start fighting each other.
I know I didn't explain her at the
beginning the video, either, but Captain Cold's sister,
that we saw the tease of at the end, in
the comic she's known as Golden Glider.
She's a full-on rogue, she does have powers, she commits crimes with them.
But she has the ability to phase through
walls.
The Person playing her is Peyton List from
the Tomorrow People.
I don't know if she's ever going to get
any scenes with Robbie Amell
doing Firestorm stuff, but that would be
so much fun. I'm not expecting it.
So now you can add the Tomorrow People to  the list of shows that the Flash and Arrow pull from.
You have Prison Break, Spartacus and now the Tomorrow People.
I have no idea which episode Lisa Snart
is going to show up in for the first
time, they made it seem like she's going to
show up next week even though next week is
supposedly a Pied Piper heavy episode.
As soon as she does show up we can talk
a lot more about her.
Here's my big question for you guys:
do you think that Eddie Thawne is going to
start developing
kind of a side partnership with the
Flash, you know, teaming up to take down criminals,
without knowing he's Barry Allen. Do you
think that that's going to develop between the two of them?
So, time for easter eggs, so there are actually a whole bunch in the episode.
I think I already mentioned a lot of them
so I'll brush through these really quick.
Barry Allen says he's not the fastest
man alive, that distinction goes to the reverse flash.
In the comics, zoom, the Hunter Zolomon zoom, actually becomes faster than the Flash
because his powers are based on a different principle.
When Harrison Wells says, "After this past Christmas I think he poses a threat to both of us,"
talking about captain cold,
the cold gun is the only known weapon
that's effective
against the Flash and the reverse flash's
powers.
Inside Barry Allen's childhood backpack there's a space ghost comic. Space Ghost Coast to Coast that's
all I could think about.
The first time I saw it I actually thought it was a Batman comic but then I looked at
it the second time I saw that the Space
Ghost.
Jason Rush also name-dropped Mercury Labs. Now we visited there
in Episode 9 but Max Mercury was part
of the Flash family,
and Andrew Kreisburg at the TCA's recently said that
this back half of the season is going to
fully explore
the lore of the reverse flash. When he
said it he made it sound like they're
going to incorporate all aspects to the reverse flash, not just one or two reverse flashes, but several from the comics.
I've already done a video for all
the different reverse flashes
so I'll add a link to that in the description if you guys wanna learn more about the different versions.
If you saw any other easter eggs that I didn't mention just write them below in the comments,
or actually ghostbusters, although I did mention that, although I love the idea that Cisco
said that it's scientifically accurate.
Actually I don't know that it is, but it
might be. So there are a couple thumbs down
I had on the episode just a couple things
that I feel didn't work quite as well as they could have.
So, just the idea of people living at
their parent's houses
beyond a certain, age that just kinda bugs
me a little bit. They're kinda fuzzy on how
old Barry and Iris are, I would say
mid-twenties maybe.
So I guess you could believe them
living at Joes house. If you really think
about, it'd be much more practical for
Barry to just go live at Star labs
and then Caitlin talking to Jason Rush about this big mystery big plot
they're trying to tease I feel like they
you know quote-unquote rushed that
a little bit not to make too many puns
but I feel like they're trying to set this huge mystery plot
that's going to involve the military and a bunch of other characters
and it just felt like they dived into that too fast
like it was a little unbelievable how
quickly he got crazy
in that meeting and he actually did come
off a little bit crazy, "They're after me."
I kept wondering if I missed a scene, I was
like, maybe I missed the line or something.
Overall I thought was a really strong
episode, great way to bring us back
into the season and tease the idea of
all these new rogues showing up,
as well as all this Firestorm stuff. I'm sure
you guys have a ton to questions about
the comic book characters as well as Harrison Wells,
reverse flash stuff, Eddie Thawne, so leave everything in the comments. I will be
doing a Q&A for Arrow and the Flash
on Thursday, but I'll try to answer as many comments on this video in the comments as possible.
in related news, tomorrow, I'm actually
gonna be going on CW fan talk
I'm supposed to be on with Emily Bett Rickards so I don't know how it's gonna go
I could embarrass myself quite a bit
it's gonna be a lot of fun either way.
I won't be uploading that video, it's not
my show, but if you follow me on Twitter
i'll tweet the link out before I go on. It's
gonna start at 4 p.m. Pacific time,
so it'll go on an hour before Arrow airs.
That video for Arrow will post just after the episode airs, just like normal.
So be sure to subscribe to get
everything, if you have any special requests
for the Q&A or anything you want me to include, just let me know .
While you guys wait for that to happen you can click here to learn more about Heatwave from the comics for
his character history and you can click here for my new weekly facepalm video it is
gonna be a catch-all for stuff
that doesn't necessarily fit into like
Star Wars or Avengers or
Arrow or Flash videos. So thank you so much for watching, let's all high five,
I will see you guys tomorrow!